at the opening of his trial in lüneburg
the former Nazi SS guard asked for
forgiveness I share morally in the guilt
oscar guling told the court the 93 year
old admits that he had learned jews were
being killed shortly after his arrival
at auschwitz concentration camp
the prosecution accuses him of accessory
to murder in the deaths of at least
300,000 people as an active member of
the vafan SS the defendant is said to
have taken the money of prisoners in the
camp he's alleged to have counted the
banknotes in the luggage of newly
arrived detainees and forwarded the
money to SS headquarters in Berlin
joining is said to have asked three
times for a transfer out of Auschwitz
his defense maintains he's not guilty
legally this process is very difficult
because individual guilt must always be
established in addition there's the
moral aspect that's undisputed and
that's something that should be
discussed at a different level more than
60 Auschwitz survivors and relatives of
the victims have come from around the
world to attend the proceedings if Oskar
Gruening is found guilty and declared
fit for prison he faces at least three
years behind bars